foreign
for
[Music]
yes let's go
[Music]
[ __ ] crimes yes
[Music]
I love these thought crimes
thought crimes
what a [ __ ] crop we have today all
right
um see I'm I'm now just trying to find
all the good looking ones because we got
a crop we got a crop today boys it's a
good crop uh let's let's check it let's
check them out all right this is very
Puerto ricany uh all right here we go oh
Jesus oh that is aggressively Puerto
Rican
um battery yeah it's all I'm gonna salt
battery they're Puerto Rican it's Puerto
Rican come on look at her she looks like
she wants to hit me through the screen
oh my all she wants I know that look at
people
it's the no-nonsense look right she's
very angry
um did you say anything
yeah assault
okay everyone's assault huh yeah no
we're disorderly conduct which is
downgraded assault
unfortunately you guys are all wrong it
was theft
why that was my second guess that would
have been my second guess stole our
hearts she was Puerto Rican
all right I almost forgot I forgot to
have my little music put on hold on here
we go look at her face yeah I did it
I think we could all agree though that
even though she didn't get she was
arrested for theft that day she also did
assault someone that day she's Puerto
Rican
hold on this is who is this
I like this one I like this um I'm going
with
um DUI or drugs drugs possession maybe
paraphernalia would be my guess
she looks High
yeah because I yeah let me check the
local UI
oh okay I what do we got Frozen
well guys uh you're gonna like this one
and hopefully Pepsi can find this one
indecent exposure she was arrested for
making on only fat or making only fans
content in a public library what's her
name what are those girls yeah what's
her name what's her name it has her name
Macy Jade Macy
[Music]
get on it
holy [ __ ]
she has okay please please and by the
way past you know where you post them
locals chat that way the people that pay
get a little taste
um
oh yeah all right let's
did you find that did you find some I
found her Twitter okay is it good
oh wait hold on is it a good Twitter
okay hold on
oh boy oh we got video we got video oh
yeah she's up on websites and [ __ ] oh
yeah she's popular she is a porn actress
this one that's not difficult um I will
put it in the locals chat momentarily
just hold tight guys
oh I'm gonna hold tight don't worry uh
karaoke twenty dollars Merry Christmas
thank you thank you thank you she has
the faces whoa hold on let me take my
glasses off so that it doesn't you got
it yeah I got it I don't want it I don't
want it to reflect look in the locals
chat in the local chat you know what I
gotta give her credit
she's done so many cop themed pornos
that it actually kind of took care of
the uh arrest in her SEO very smart
she has very if you Google Macy Jay to
rest it doesn't come up with any
official news articles about real cops
are you telling me there's a lot of
people in cop outfits that are [ __ ]
her
I don't think that's trial footage you
know what a little thicker than I
thought but I like it oh I'll take it
that's nice I like that that no no wait
by the way we know best
[Laughter]
cushion for the pushes nice nipples I I
like the piercings
yeah all right what a what a bonus
thought crimes okay this is good okay
guys I have a question Frozen
um what library and have they cleaned
the carpets yet
okay all right dude don't go smell the
carp come on man I don't think that whoa
whoa whoa look at that one whoa
Baby Got Back
we got a lot of one dick
God she is hot holy [ __ ] anyway okay
guys [ __ ] you guys posting this [ __ ] the
locals chat it's all those locals yeah
the premium chat oh in general yeah and
the like the 24 7 Premium show chat oh
yeah locals all right sorry yeah
I do I'm the same yeah look at that yeah
nice nice right nice right scroll up
Scroll up Scroll up a little bit look at
the Box
nice bro bro bro
what's your favorite one I like this one
bro good for you Macy I'll be tugging
one out to you tonight yeah hell yeah we
all will we all will uh Merry Christmas
everyone we're all gonna be what was it
yeah okay so when you both when everyone
jerks off to the same girl your Eskimo
pen pals not Eskimo brothers
um this is she is fine
wow her tits are great
okay anyway guys we have other
contestants guys we have three more it
don't matter
I'm Gonna Save this one for last I I'm
gonna put my glasses back on now and
there we go okay so
um
guys
Focus those tits in the local chat are
nice
oh uh California obviously California
all right we got another one here guys
uh here we go
um oh
domestic
um she's been crying look around her
eyes yeah
yeah this is the domestic assault fight
nah might not be domestic assault I'm
gonna just fight I'm gonna okay
I go drugs all right uh what do you
think
well guys it is uh disorderly conduct
that's like first that earlier
downgraded assault
foreign
let's see next okay here we go
okay
um
[Music]
hello
uh hosting raw talk
uh okay that's come on
um
prostitution or drugs yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna say drugs on this one
okay
uh so guys again you're wrong uh
resisting arrest and threatening an
officer and vandalism of over five
thousand and over she scratched the car
she keyed a car she keyed a car yeah
because that's a big [ __ ] vandalism
bill
all right then we have this one uh boss
battle oh this is a rough okay it's
gonna be a bad one okay
um
definitely drugs
nah I something more sinister
baby and microwave
kill their baby try no no I'm gonna go
with assault with a deadly weapon
assaulting a baby on a baby yes
hold on hold on
beating up
with another baby with another baby yes
okay so what do we think guys
that's a Hail Mary play by Royce yeah a
lot of people that babies in here Jesus
Christ wielding babies like the weirdest
God of War [ __ ] wrong if I like
blades
I thought the dead baby gimmick was JJ's
what is going on I don't know but last
time you said last every time you do
boss battles it's something [ __ ]
insane the other one we was a woman was
cutting up a guy and keep on putting him
in a microwave and [ __ ] froze it I have
a serious answer okay tied two babies
together by the ankle with rope and had
like a baby nunchucks
look
tell me what she did with the babies
Frozen
it was still babies involved in this
okay well that's a life right yeah
murder with the use of a deadly weapon
her and a man friend murdered a woman
dismembered her body and put it in a 55
gallon barrel to hide it
nice all right so that's adjacent to
Baby murder we were close okay I can't
fix her what is what is a person if not
a grown-up baby
um so I have I have a little bonus one
since we're putting pretty people up
what about this one
ha ha
ha okay let me guess all right let's
guess let's go okay okay
all right
you guys are [ __ ]
criminals this buddy reality
I I got it I got it I'm gonna guess
being the most handsomest boy on Rumble
that's what I'm guessing the most
handsomest boy on Rumble they arrested
you for that right
that's me
look at that handsome man [ __ ] the owner
of baby dolls that night and I [ __ ]
scratch it on him and see
again we're back to that
I thought you would appreciate that one
you're a thought merge congratulations
okay
oh [ __ ]
um
so much oh [ __ ] uh somebody was guessing
on the Merchant's picture making 20
bucks the hard way